die weltgesundheitsorganisation who hat
den internationalen gesundheitsnotfall
ausgerufen
dass sika virus breitet sich nämlich
immer schneller aus steht uns eine neue
pandemie bevor und es gibt was zu
gewinnen diesen experimentierkasten von
kosmos zum thema nanotechnologie klicks
um science-fiction los geht's
sehen wir uns erstmal die grundlegenden
fakten zu ca
das virus gehört zu den klavieren die
werden so im schnitt 50 nanometer groß
und werden häufig über insektenstiche
übertragen
zur gleichen gattung gehört auch das
virus dass das gelbfieber beim menschen
auslöst das syker virus kann bisher
eigentlich nur auf dem westlichen
afrikanischen kontinent vor überträgt
eine mücke die zur gattung eines gehört
das virus auf einen menschen können
grippeähnliche symptome auftreten ca
fieber genannt vor einigen jahren im
jahr 2007 tauchte es dann auch in
anderen ländern auf zunächst den
ozeanien deshalb wurde das virus dann
als er merching pathogen eingestuft also
als virus das sich potenziell noch
weiter verbreiten wird bis dato war die
zahl der betroffenen menschen noch sehr
gering 2007 waren gerade mal 15 fälle
bekannt in der folgenden zeit wurden
fälle vor allem auf der südlichen
halbkugel gemeldet mittel und südamerika
waren zum beispiel auch betroffen jetzt
ist die zigarette me weit von dem
managen pathogens status entfernt die wa
erklärte den virus zum internationalen
gesundheitsnotfall wird etwas zum
internationalen gesundheitsnotfall
erklärt besteht die gefahr dass sich die
lage auch für viele andere länder
drastisch verschlechtern
zudem sei eine weltweite reaktion
erforderlich eine kleine info am rand
bei der ebola epidemie rief die whu den
notstand einigen
untersuchungskommissionen zur folge
übrigens zu spät aus derzeit grassiert
das zita virus noch in mittel und
südamerika rund 20 prozent der
infizierten erkranken am ca fieber
der krankheitsverlauf ist eigentlich
nicht gefährlich bisher ist noch niemand
daran gestorben wenn sich allerdings
eine schwangere frau infiziert ist es
aber möglich dass sich die infektion auf
das ungeborene kind überträgt man geht
derzeit davon aus dass es zu
mikrozephalie kommen kann
dabei ist der kopf des neugeborenen viel
zu klein
was oft mit einer geistigen behinderung
hier geht die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who meldet
4000 fälle von mikrozephalie die mit
sika in verbindung stehen könnten
allerdings gibt es keine beweise da in
diesen zahlen auch verdachtsfälle
enthalten sind und da die kriterien
verändert wurden wie die krankheit
bewertet wird kann es also sein dass die
zahlen der vero total falsch sind
mikrozephalie könnte auch andere
ursachen haben wie zum beispiel
drogenkonsum und hier eben auch alkohol
einen rückschluss zu ziehen dass das
virus und die missbildung im
zusammenhang stehen wäre also noch
vorstellen
das gesundheitsministerium von brasilien
hat auf seiner webseite auch zahlen
veröffentlicht da bleiben nur sechs
fälle übrig in denen eine mikrozephalie
aufgrund des zita virus nachgewiesen
wurde
daraus kann man also schließen dass
selbst bei einer infektion der mutter
durch das virus eine übertragung auf das
kind eher selten vorkommt aber vorsicht
das sind alles nur vermutungen in die
eine wie auch in die andere richtung
allerdings konkrete antworten wie haben
die experten noch nicht tropenmediziner
peter hotels erklärt dem gespräch mit
der faz also der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung zitat die situation ist für uns
alle frustrieren viele fragen können wir
noch nicht beantworten und wir setzen
nun puzzleteile zusammen was wissen wir
über verwandte viren und solche die in
der schwangerschaft übertragen werden
und zu viel bildung führen wann ist die
gefahr am größten was hilft zitat ende
roth sieht bei der möglichkeit die
mücken zu bekämpfen auch die möglichkeit
andere gentechnisch veränderte mücken
einzusetzen dabei werden die insekten
bestrahlt und können sich dann nicht
mehr vermehren wenn man diese insekten
großflächig in die mücken populationen
einbringen würde kann dass die mücken
dezimieren auch mit pestiziden versuchen
die behörden in den betroffenen gebieten
gegen die mücken vorzugehen in brasilien
werden dazu jetzt 550 tonnen pestizide
eingesetzt
damit will man allerdings nicht nur die
übertragung von ca verhindern sondern
auch die des dengue fiebers das viel
gefährlicher ist daran starben letztes
jahr 863 menschen das auswärtige amt und
die deutsche gesellschaft für
tropenmedizin warnen schwangere übrigens
davor in den betroffenen gegenden zu
reisen glaubt ihr dass die ganze
angelegenheit mit dem c a virus zu
panisch gesehen wird oder müssen wir uns
wirklich vor einer pandemie fürchten
diskutiert mit uns in den kommentaren
abonniert den kanal ist er kostenlos
teilt das video und ich freue mich sehr
über jeden daumen hoch für das video und
bevor er schluss ist das gewinnspiel für
alle pixum abonnenten
ich habe diesen genialen
experimentierkasten bekommt muss zum
thema nanotechnologie
damit kann man zum beispiel solche
fantastischen experimente machen
schreibt in die kommentare welches video
euch am besten gefallen hat und
beantwortet folgende frage wie viel
heller als die sonne war die hälfte
bisher beobachtete supernova könnte
vielleicht in einem der videos aus dem
januar erfahren schreibt eure antwort an
klicks um eddie mail.com links ist der
link ist in der video beschreibung und
bei mehreren richtigen antworten
entscheidet das los ja bis zum nächsten
mal bis dann bleibt dran